[Music]
owen is with us in newark new jersey hey
owen your question for
rachel and me well congratulations
rachel on your book
thank you owen i'm graduating you're
awesome i'm graduating in may and i have
a very generous job lined up
and i was wondering how you would advise
a 22 year old who's transitioning from
being a college student making a
full-time
income um of course i'm going to get my
emergency fund set up and using my
full 401k match but uh there's going to
be leftover income
and i don't want to waste it oh and do
you have any debt
currently when you graduate you have
student loans or credit card debt
no i was fortunate enough to get a nice
dollar oh awesome
amazing uh i mean yeah i mean i would
say owen number one the fact you're
asking the question
is encouraging because you're going to
be starting this process at 22 which is
incredible
so yeah i mean it's exactly what you
just said just making having some cash
on the side for an emergency fund three
to six months of expenses
and then looking into retirement and
funding that 15
from there and then and even in the
process if i wouldn't buy a house right
out of college but having some
savings if you want to save up for a
down payment on a home because you know
that may be coming later in life
uh doing that too how much are you going
to be making at your new job
uh 157 plus a little stock good night
owen what are you doing
what's your duet software
software development yes yeah software
engineering
okay wow nice owen that's a great very
impressive young man that's a very good
very impressive out of college to give
you an idea i made
exactly ten percent when i came out of
college or what you're going to be
making when you come out
34. so
yeah i think you have a bright future
sir you're going to be okay don't screw
it up
wow got a fight free ride somehow and
comes out because you're smart i'm
scared
i got a feeling you're a smart guy
academic scholarship
yeah we didn't have any of those either
hey hey hey no i'm talking about me too
[Laughter]
oh and that's awesome way to go owen way
to go yeah just save up some money pile
up some money get ready for your home
purchase above your emergency fund
above 15 of your income i think you
already knew the answer to this
congratulations
you are a stud well done okay so how do
you feel
sitting in your chair doing the show how
long have you been doing the show 30
30 years you're getting more young
people calling you
than ever before would you say i think
it's a youtube thing
okay the demographic on youtube do you
feel like a grandfather of america or
you're like these young
i used to be i used to be your peer when
you called
and i have evolved into uh then i went
to uncle dave and now i'm just straight
up papa dave yeah
there's no question about it yeah i mean
the the the guys calling are younger
than my kids
no if that didn't happen 30 years no
it didn't it was like guys in their 60s
calling you hey
back in the day right no well i mean
still i'll say great america
there's a hope for the future there's a
lot of young people like owens
yeah that's awesome well and i i'll bet
you dollars to donuts that he was a
youtube
listener probably not an a.m
i don't know he could be you never know
but um there's how it works
wow that's awesome owen so proud of you
sir very well done